es ist wieder jahresrückblicks saison
und leider fällt dieser art sendung auch
2021 ziemlich monothematisch aus corona
und kein ende deutschland diskutiert die
einführung der allgemeinen impfpflicht
die man sich in jedem fall erspart hätte
mit rechtzeitig zweig aber jetzt gibt
zur verhinderung einer dauerwelle
vielleicht nur noch die wahl zwischen
impfpflicht oder durchseuchung an der
bekanntlich auch unschuldige sterben zum
beispiel menschen die in der falschen
stadt einen herzinfarkt kriegen leider
wäre die allgemeine impfpflicht
inklusive wortbruch der politik aber
auch ein super geschenk an die af.de die
original nichts beiträgt zur lösung
außer lügen
ich werde ja trotzdem krank und ich habe
eine andere anstecken sind weißweine
partys anhalt aber in den krankenhäusern
sind überwiegend um geimpfte auf den
intensivstationen sehen würde ich
natürlich stimmt ist in überwiegend
gehen die zahlen warum sie ihre her nein
stimmt nicht
sie sagen stimmt nicht stimmt wohl die
neue polit-talkshow im kicker da lobe
ich mir deutschlands große firmen die
versuchen wenigstens zu helfen mit neuen
werbeslogans pro impfkampagne da ist
viel schöner ist dabei netto zum
beispiel dann jedoch zum impfen otto
impfen finde ich gut genau wie los im
fokus mit einer spritze in jedem happy
meal ist eine super idee meint auch das
zdf ab sofort im programm aktenzeichen
xy ungelöst leider kein einzelfall
für die romantiker inga rumpf strömen
und natürlich rosamontis pfizer booster
der leidenschaft aber zurück zur
allgemeinen pflicht ich finde wenn man
wenn man so eine heftige grundrechts
einschränkung wirklich vornimmt als
letztes mittel muss der staat aber
parallel seine hausaufgaben machen oder
anders formuliert impfpflicht einerseits
und andererseits leute die nach
stundenlangem warten in der schlange
wieder weggeschickt werden das passt
irgendwie nicht zusammen da muss man
endlich aus dem quark kommen und das
gilt übrigens auch für unsere ständige
impfkommission stiko
ich sagte es oder
aus heutiger sicht wäre es
wahrscheinlich günstiger gewesen mit den
bussen früher anzufangen
ja wahrscheinlich und ja gründliche
datenprüfung bleibt wichtig und das
eigentliche problem sind natürlich
politiker die nichts entscheiden aus
feigheit und sich dann hinter der stiko
verstecken trotzdem passend pandemie und
das ehrenamtliche feierabend gremium
stiko
offensichtlich nicht so gut zusammen
hallo geben sie mir die ständige
impfkommission schnell
hier steht hallo ich bin in einem bus
und wenn er langsamer fährt als 50
explodiert eine bombe
was soll ich machen
schwer zu sagen bei der datenlage
ich könnte das nachher mal mit meinen
stiko kollegen in der video schalte
besprechen
welches baujahr ist denn der bus
was keine ahnung welche farbe der
weiß ich doch nicht warum ist denn die
farbe wichtig vorschlag ich würde
erstmal alle über 70 jährigen aussteigen
lassen
ach ja und alle unter 70 auch fällt mir
gerade ein
hallo arschloch einfach aufgelegt
jetzt träumen bald nicht im kino und
wenn dann garantiert ohne zuschauer so
holger stockhaus ist in olaf scholz
neuem krisenstab zuständig für das
monitoring der impfkampagne
herr stockhaus sekunde wenngleich bei
ihnen habe hier noch ein kleines
problemchen ok alles klar die hälfte der
bestellten dosen kommt ja verstehe er
alles klar
so wie wir die frage ja ich wollte mal
fragen wie die impfkampagne so läuft
super die läuft super absolut top keine
klagen seit olaf scholz versprochen hat
dass wir bis weihnachten 30 millionen
menschen impfen ist mein leben geträumt
in 30 millionen das wären 1,3 millionen
spritzen jeden tag inklusive wochenende
so da gucke ich mal ganz kurz in meinen
im kalender letzten sonntag waren es
250.000 da steht uns also nur ein
milliönchen am montag
693 das ist schon fast die hälfte und
dienstag halo eine million cooper herr
wirke nur an diesen drei tagen liegen
der lächerliche zwei millionen unter
solchen
aber hey jetzt werden ja viele
impfzentren wieder hochgefahren es ist
eine frage von wochen höchstens monaten
und dann muss uns vielleicht noch was
einfallen wie wir das mit dem impfstoff
bestellen ich sag mal optimieren jeweils
dienstags bis 12 uhr müssen die ärzte
den impfstoff beim apotheker bestellen
der meldet dass dem großhandel über das
bundesgesundheitsministerium geht die
meldung an das bundeswehr zentraler das
von biontech und moderner beliefert wird
in kleinen päckchen geht es dann den
ganzen weg zurück erst montag fast eine
woche später wird geliefert
zugegeben das wird für den laien erst
mal umständlich aber da sind wir längst
dran nach einem brainstorming bei uns im
krisenstab läuft das bald so die ärzte
bestellen impfstoff bei den apotheken
die apotheker rufen dann bei markus lanz
an und fragen ob sie kurz karl
lauterbach sprechen können wenn ja
twittert kann die bestellung das ließ
dann jemand bei der bundeswehr mit und
die schickt dann einen dritten boten zum
zentrallager von brot nur wenige wochen
später die bestellung rausgeht viel
besser in der nächsten woche nur als
beispiel bekommen die ärzte nicht mehr
die hälfte der bestellten biontech dosen
der konzern sagt sie arbeiten nach
vertrag und plan und ich sage mal es
gibt hinweise dass unser
gesundheitsministerium nicht mit der
starken booster nachfrage der bürger
gerechnet hat daraus ergibt sich für
mich die frage was ja sorry nur weil man
die bürger monatelang an schreit jetzt
geht endlich alle mal impfen kann man ja
nicht ahnen dass die alle impfen gehen
kann positiv denken schon in wenigen
wochen impfen in deutschland auch die
apotheker frankreich dämpfen die seit
mitte märz frankreichs mir das
scheißegal
wir haben hier noch einen ganzen sack
voll anderer ideen beispiel die
deutschen lieben doch neuerdings den
dartsport also schicken wir dort profis
in die innenstädte und wo immer leute
wütend auf ihre spritze warten kürzen
die den vorgang ab
genial oder was wir im krisenstab gerade
gegoogelt haben es gibt wohl einen
konzern der sich mit logistik richtig
gut auskennt die machen das beruflich
die firma nennt sich amazon die können
voll gut dinge von a nach b bringen
manchmal an einem tag habe ich schon von
gehört die zahlen leider keine steuern
amazon das ist doch die lösung dann
heißt es bald für millionen deutsche
haushalte ihre impfdosen wurde beim
nachbarn abgegeben besser als jetzt
holger stockhaus
[Gelächter]
jeff bezos beste lache der welt ja es
stimmt schon wir haben hier aktuell ein
mittelschweres logistikprobleme ist eine
tatsache und das müssen wir jetzt lösen
sonst brauchen wir über impfpflicht gar
nicht zu diskutieren
laut einer aktuellen insa umfrage sagen
63 prozent der umkämpften deutschen sie
würden sich auch in zukunft nicht impfen
lassen kann man diese leute überhaupt
noch irgendwie erreichen mit dem dass
wir älteren früher fakten nannten zb
beim thema corona tote ich sehe die
zahlen medial aber ich spüre dass auch
nicht man hört medial auch immer wieder
werde ich nicht geimpft gewesen wäre ich
gestorben
zieht bei mir auch nicht weil er das
nicht weiß das zieht bei ihr nicht bei
ihr zieht er im kopf was soll man da
noch sagen wirklich was soll man da noch
sagen braucht man die impfpflicht die
allgemeine weil leute wie sie ist nicht
spüren ein slider sicher ein teil der
impfgegner wird sich dann noch weiter
radikalisieren
zumindest in sachsen ist die szene stark
von rechtsextremen unterwandert jedes
dramatische loleit vom letzten
wochenende ein nazi fackel mob stellt
sich grün vor das haus der sächsischen
gesundheitsministerin petra köpping
natürlich um sie einzuschüchtern es ist
einfach nur ekelhaft und solche
aufmärsche werden gern als spontane
spaziergänge getan das ist der trick
meistens bei telegramm orchestriert von
einer gruppe namens freie sachsen in
einem anderen telegramm audio chat
wurden gerade mordpläne gegen den
sächsischen ministerpräsidenten
kretschmann geschmiedet wieder andere
üben bei ihren spaziergängen
subtile medienkritik ihr seid hier nicht
gewünscht wir sagen einfach nur
propaganda 40 45 wollen die medienleute
eine der ersten die diesen
und ich möchte nicht dass euch das auch
passiert ich möchte
er macht sich sorgen um uns eine kleine
korrektur die alliierten haben 45 keinen
einzigen nazi journalisten gehängt im
gegenteil werden erhöhte als beispiel
durfte sogar den internationalen
frühschoppen moderieren aber was viel
wichtiger ist warum warum hat die
sächsische polizei diesem mob und
anderen wochenlang tatenlos zugeguckt
und allenfalls mal die linke gegendemo
abgeräumt sie dürfen gewiss sein dass
die philosophie des sächsischen polizei
zerstört sich geändert hat seit gut
einer woche und das wird diesen corinna
gegnern auf die füße treten werden und
cool aber wieso erst seit gut einer
woche ja seit monaten gab es bei diesen
spaziergängen tätliche angriffe auf
journalisten
aber erst der fackel marsch vor dem haus
der ministerin war offenbar ein weckruf
denn seitdem werden solche
unangemeldeten corona dem muss
tatsächlich aufgelöst wir schalten live
zu dennis knossalla der im auftrag der
polizei sachsen spezielle schulungen
durchführt hat masala was genau üben sie
damit ihren leuten na ja für mich wenn
die kollegen sind das jetzt völlig neue
herausforderungen was ist ein
spaziergang was ist eine von nazis
unterwanderte dem ofc die grenzen ja
fließend selbst die journalisten können
oft nicht genau sagen was da gerade
passiert so mussten
kretschmer bock ein konvent euro
er geht den kurven in einer nacht zum 18
geht ihnen dürfen weder in kurven ist ja
nicht verboten so und jetzt versuchen
wir halt in schulungen die feinen
unterschiede herauszuarbeiten denn die
rechtslage in sachsen ist ja so
angemeldete stationäre corona dem muss
mit maximal zehn personen sind legal
also gucken wir uns zusammen einzelne
spaziergänger an
und überlegen dann gemeinsam waren das
jetzt zum beispiel mehr als sehen was
meint ihr schwierig man kann es halt nur
schätzen und ja wir haben in der
vergangenheit auch fehler gemacht im
november sehen wir zum beispiel mal auf
ein angebliches laternelaufen
reingefallen dabei gab es hinweise
leider haben viele sachsen denen auch
noch süßigkeiten gegeben ärgerlich aber
ab jetzt passen wir auf wie die
schoßhunde ich habe zb eben zu
schulungszwecken diese wandergruppe
aufgehalten so und jetzt sollen meine
kollegen mal die situation bewerten wir
haben hier also weniger als zehn
personen gepflegtes äußeres
wettergerechte funktionskleidung da
scheint ja alles in ordnung zu sein wäre
jedenfalls mein erster eindruck ok jetzt
haben plötzlich alle eine fackel in der
hand warum
dunkel
ein argument eine fackel ist im dunkeln
natürlich sehr hilfreich du siehst
einfach besser wobei jetzt ist gerade
einer der wanderer führt eine mistgabel
mit sicherheit da muss ich schon aber
nachher verbrauchen sie die kein
kommentar
alles klar dann eben doch ein
spaziergang ja klar da muss jemand doch
noch mal nachfragen warum lässt man die
jetzt weiterlaufen bitte
ja weil es in deutschland immer noch die
versammlungs- und meinungsfreiheit gibt
herr welke jedenfalls als ich das letzte
mal ins grundgesetz geguckt hat
scheiße ein linker gegendemonstranten
stört den spaziergang seiner freizeit
hier werden noch mal zeigen wer das
gewaltmonopol hat
dennis knossalla vielen dank die haben
gesagt die soll meinen lieblings witz
erzählt es mache ich gerne also kommen
ein pferd chef base und der papst in
einer bar sagt der barkeeper
sony endlich den fakten heute schon
kanal also geht doch